[Música]
bienvenido dos a cinco minutos o con
hablaremos hoy sobre las consecuencias
en la salud mental es que está dejando
la nueva ola de contagios y muertes por
cuenta del hobby 19 nos acompaña a
claudio tope el vergel doctor en
medicina y profesor en psiquiatría de la
escuela de medicina de la universidad de
harvard también psiquiatra jefe del new
england center for children gracias a
usted por acompañarnos y comienzo
preguntándole la ansiedad vuelve y sigue
en el caso de muchas personas ante las
restricciones y las medidas de
distanciamiento social para tratar de
frenar el avance del coronavirus que tan
abrumadora puede resultar esta ruleta de
emociones en la que estamos inmersos ya
en segunda y tercera ola de la pandemia
muchas gracias angela por tenerme
ciertamente digamos esta segunda ola con
los concomitantes restricciones sociales
la falta de conexión social que implica
lleva a una que llamamos de medicina
cronificación del estrés donde el estrés
que lleva a la ansiedad y la depresión y
a otras situaciones de salud mental no
es un evento limitado en el tiempo sino
que es continuo y dado la continuidad de
estos parecidos a lo que a veces ocurre
en situaciones de campos de refugiados o
de estrés crónico dado guerra sostenida
etcétera es muy importante en términos
generales para toda la población el
poder utilizar estrategias para mantener
la salud mental cosas que tienen que ver
con la resiliencia y con el manejo del
estrés crónico son habilidades que uno
una vez que las adquiere sirven para
muchas otras cosas en la vida uno no
está exento de tener situaciones de
estrés sostenidas y
es lo que tiene que ver con las medidas
preventivas acerca de la infección del
virus y están también los impactos
sociales educacionales y familiares que
llevan a este estrés por supuesto hay
gente que en particular sufre de
trastornos de salud mental no solo
estrés sino más específicamente
trastornos de la ansiedad depresión e
inclusive de cosas más graves
directamente vinculadas al impacto del
cómic y esto requiere atención
específica profesional bueno ya que
usted nos habla de un componente tan
importante como la resiliencia cuál
sería la mejor manera de atravesar este
estrés y de que ha traído esta pandemia
y se lo digo porque es una situación
normal que viven las personas es tratar
de poner el estrés a un lado
profesionales como usted recomiendan que
más bien se atraviese ese estrés de la
manera más sana posible
entonces hay medidas generales que todos
podemos utilizar para combatir el estrés
la asociación cardiológica americana
puso en forma muy sucinta lo que surge
de todo el conocimiento que tenemos en
el campo de salud mental en psicología
psiquiatría de cómo manejar el estrés y
básicamente hay tres elementos que son
fundamentales uno es el el pensamiento
positivo el no negativizar se con
respecto a uno mismo
y perdonarse porque hay limitaciones y
hay factores exteriores que llevan a que
las circunstancias sean como son y que
no son el resultado de uno mismo y luego
hay todas las estrategias que uno puede
utilizar en el corto plazo
inmediatamente para manejar un momento
de estrés y cosas como respirar meditar
y caminar en un momento de mucho estrés
porque claramente está el estrés crónico
pero hay momentos de crisis donde uno
puede enfrentar una situación
interpersonal en la casa puede haber
alguien enfermo etcétera
y por último están las actividades más
sostenidas
puede llevar que disminuciones de estrés
caminar mantener contacto social no
físico pero a través de la tecnología no
hay nada que impida con el adecuado
distanciamiento e ir a caminar afuera o
ir hacer deporte o correr con un amigo
si ambos usan máscaras y están
distanciados es decir mantener la red
social en el contacto social con amigos
y familiares y con la más familia
cercana que todo eso son protectores del
estrés en la población general
sí muchísimas gracias a usted este es un
tema que hemos tocado varias veces
durante este último año pero cabe
seguirlo recordando y pedirles a
nuestros televidentes que traten de
mantener una vida sana sigan con
nosotros en france 24
[Música]